سالنا الناس في السودان من برايكم سيفوز
بالمونديال ولماذا
[موسيقى]
الفريق اللي عنده خبره ومنسيم وناسه
شغالين كويس مع بعض وكده منتخب فرنسا
همم يمكن لي عناصر شابه كثيره جدا في
المنتخب يمكن لي ميسي في اخر كاس عالم
انا افتكر انها هي المرشحه اصلا رياضي
بشوف انه المنتخب البرازيل
منتخب كويس في نجوم في شباب في لعبه خبره
يعني نيمار كذا ميرو اليسون حارس ليفربول
فينيسيوس لاعب ريال مدريد يعني خبراته
كويسه هو همم بالاضافه انه مدربهم كويس
والبرازيل شعب بيحب الكوره فطوالي هم
متعلقين يعني في في الكوره العالميه يعني
شايف انه فرسه افضل
قطر
سواهم يتقدم في المنافسه او لم يتقدموا
انما تنظيمهم لكاس العالم
اما بخصوص توقعات يعني المعادله بتقول
الارجنتين